Tage an denen die Sonne nicht aufzugehen
scheint davon gibt es viele in
Jakarta Tage an denen die Luft
unerträglich ist das Atmen eine Qual
auch davon gibt es viele in
Jakarta Tage an denen die Straßen aus
allen nähtenplatzen der Verkehr erdrückt
fast jeder Tag ist so in
Jakarta geschätzte 4 Millionen Menschen
leben in der Metropolregion lebenswert
kann man es kaum nennen
[Musik]
aber das größte Problem ist ein anderes
Indonesiens Hauptstadt droht der
Untergang die Reste der Moschee sind
noch da noch viele andere Häuser im
Norden Jakartas sind schon versunken das
Wasser holt sich die Stadt mehr als die
Hälfte liegt bereits unterhalb des
Meeresspiegels die Leute ziehen dahin wo
es höher ist an höher gelegene Plätze
sie wollen nicht überflutet werden ich
schätze dass ich auch bald hier weg
muss immer höher bauen Sie die Mauern
die schützen sollen der Klimawandel
lässt den Meeresspiegel steigen aber
bedrohlicher noch das Land versinkt um
bis zu 25 cm jedes Jahr 2,50 m in 10
[Musik]
Jahr haben wir unser Haus fünfm höher
gesetzt jedesm alles auseinander gebaut
Material kaufen Holz Nägel die Fassade
runter und wieder rauf solange sie hält
und wenn das Holz noch gut ist verwenden
wir es auch
wieder nur knapp die Hälfte aller
Haushalte hier ist an die
Wasserversorgung angeschlossen die
anderen pumkten Grundwasser versorgen
sich selbst damit deshalb sinkt der
Boden deshalb suft Jakarta ab Sinnbild
einer hauptstad deren zu gro
werden die Herausforderungen kennen Sie
die Antworten suchen Sie Stadtplaner
brüten seit Jahrzehnten über Konzepten
die Jakarta retten sollen neue Straßen
Hochbahnen Versorgungswege manches
brachte Linderung nichts die
Lösung jetzt aber arbeiten sie am ganz
großen Wurf der Flucht nach
vor eine andere Insel eine andere Region
kimantan eine neue Hauptstadt nusantara
der Image Film mutet traumhaft an eine
saubere Stadt in der nur Elektroautos
fahren wo die Luft so rein und pur ist
eine Stadt ohne Dreck ohne Müll ohne
Stau ein
antijartter das wird eine einzigartige
Kapitale mit einem ganz eigenen
Charakter grün Smart inklusiv resilient
intelligent natürlich wollen wir eine
nachhaltige Stadt erschaffen für die
Zukunft einzigartig eine Stadt im Wald
und das gibt es sonst nicht auf der Welt
es gibt wohl kein anderes Land auf der
Welt das sagen kann unsere Hauptstadt
ist eine
Waldstadt dafür jedoch muss erstmal Wald
weichen Schneisen sind geschlagen
gefräßig kommen die Bagger voran und mit
jedem Tag der vergeht kann man erkennen
sie meinen es ernst aus der Vision wird
Wirklichkeit die Pläne weisen eine
Fläche zu fast dreimal so groß wie
Berlin 2045 sollen hier knapp 2
Millionen Menschen wohnen der
Präsidentenpalast soll als erstes fertig
werden eine Signalwirkung die so hoffen
sie Sogwirkung hat denn bei den rund 30
Milliarden Euro die der Staat investiert
kann und darf es nicht bleiben gesucht
werden private Investoren und ihr
Geld wir wollen vermeiden dass
Interessenten irgendeine Enttäuschung
erleben wenn sie nach nusantara kommen
sie sollen wissen der Umzug ist ein
Vergnügen das wird gut hier und ich
denke es gibt einen gehörigen Appetit
bei privaten Investoren sie müssen nur
sehen dass es vorangeht das ist die
Faustregel du musst schon was sehen vor
Ort einer muss der Pionier sein wenn du
dann die kritische Masse erreicht hast
dann ist das unaufhaltsam das ist ein
Schneeballeffekt es ist genau was andere
fürchten Borneo hat noch intakten
Regenwald die Heimat der letzten
orangutans deren Schutzgebiete blieben
unberührt versichert die Regierung aber
ist das garantiert wenn nusantara wächst
und wuchert zu Magneten wird für
Menschen die Jobs und Häuser
suchen auch die Einheimischen sind
skeptisch das Leben wie sie es hier seit
ewigen Zeiten kennen wird es nicht mehr
lange
geben viele kleine Dörfer sind
inzwischen verschwunden pandi fürchtet
dass auch Seins bald wird weichen müssen
ich bin wütend erstens nehmen sie uns
unsere Siedlung zweitens unsere heiligen
Städten drittens meine Eltern unsere
Vorfahren sie haben schon hier gelebt da
hatten wir noch einen
König wenn Sie jetzt unser Dorf
zerstören dann können wir das nicht
akzeptieren ich rede nicht von Gewalt
aber wir müssen uns wehren und hoffen
dass es Gerechtigkeit gibt um gefährdete
Tiere sorgen Sie sich vielleicht noch um
uns nicht wir wollen hier weiter
doch die Zukunft droht sie zu überrollen
gestern lebten sie hier noch
abgeschieden morgen soll das der Nabel
Indonesiens sein es ist viel verlangt
das alles nur als Fortschritt zu
verbuchen ich hoffe dass Regierung und
Behörden auch an unsere Kinder denken an
ihre
Zukunft sie brauchen Jobs auf den
Plantagen das war
immersere wenn es auch die nicht mehr
gibt dann muss man unsere Kinder besser
ausbilden s dass sie teilhaben können
man hat ihn ja Bildung und Jobs
versprochen aber wenn sie in nusantara
arbeiten dürfen dann nur als
Toilettenreiniger ein Neubeginn soll
nusantara sein der Aufbruch in eine neue
Zeit für ganz Indonesien eine Stadt wie
ein großes Versprechen ein Magnet für
Ambitionen klein fängt es an wächst und
wächst das allerdings war bei Jakarta
auch mal
[Musik]
so